This morning, CNN has learned
that this woman has been detained
by Russian authorities in connection
with Sunday's deadly
bombing at a cafe in Saint Petersburg.
Here is the moment
we want to show you that it injured
the moment of the blast.
You see it right there.
It injured more than 30
people, killed a prominent
military blogger
known to be
a major supporter
of Russia's invasion of Ukraine.
The Kremlin has said that Ukraine
could be behind the attack.
However, no
evidence has been presented yet
to support that claim.
And then there
is this newly released video which shows
the same woman now
under arrest
outside the cafe that same day
carrying a box.
And Russian media have also put out
photographs of that woman
standing near the blogger who was killed.
This was just inside the cafe
right before the explosion.
CNN's Fred Pleitgen is following
all of this from Berlin.
He's joining us now.
Fred,
what are we learning about
this woman who has been
who has just been detained
Well, our name is Daria Trepova.
And right now,
this is an anti-terror investigation.
As far as the Russians are concerned.
It was quite interesting
because just a couple of hours ago,
the Russians
put out a video of her
apparently being interrogated
by that anti-terror committee.
And she was asked, look,
do you know why you're here?
And she said, yes,
because I gave the figurine to
Vladlen Tatarsky.
You, of course, is that
military blogger who was killed.
She was then asked
who she got
that figurine from,
and she said that she didn't want to say
at that point in time.
So clearly,
they are already confronting her
with that.
And we did see those photographs also
on that video of her
apparently going inside that cafe
with that box
We also have an eyewitness testimony
of someone
who saw her give that to Vlad in tatters.
I want to read you what
that eyewitness said.
She said, quote,
When she gifted him the figurine
she went to sit
in a different place at the window,
so obviously away from the stage
where the explosion took place.
The host at the stage
took the figurine from the box
and showcased it Vlad,
and held it for a bit.
They put it back and shortly
after the explosion happened.
That's sort of a run down.
What happened then?
Her husband dropped off his husband.
He came out earlier today
and he said
he believes that she was framed, that
she didn't know what was inside
the figurine that she gifted to that
military blogger.
Obviously,
you already saying that
the Russians are saying
that the Ukrainians might be behind.
The Ukrainians are already denying that.
They're also saying
that they believe
that she had contact with Alexei Navalny
Navalny's organization, of course,
the opposition leader.
That organization has also
denied that as well, Kate.
What else are you learning
about the military blogger who was killed
So, I think I think one of the things
to make clear to our viewers
is I think military blogger is probably
an understatement on the face of it.
That's what Vlad and to task was,
he was very prominent in that sphere.
He had more than 500,000 followers
on Telegram.
But these military bloggers
essentially are supporters of the war
in Ukraine.
And one of the thing
that's interesting about them
is that they embed quite frequently
with Russian forces there.
It's also something that Vlad into task
did as well.
But they are also among
the few people
who are allowed
to criticize
the way that the war is being led.
It doesn't mean they're against it.
In fact, they are for it.
But they want the Russians
to be even tougher and be more brutal.
That's one of the things that Vlad
and the task
he also did
and one of the things
that he notoriously did
is when Russia announced
the annexation
of four territories in Ukraine,
He essentially said
that the Russians would kill anyone
who stood in their way
and would loot any one
that they wanted to as well.
So certainly he was someone
who was hated
by the Ukrainians,
definitely someone
who was in favor of the war,
but also someone who criticized the way
that the Russian military is doing it
for the way for
for allegedly not being tough enough
and knowing all that.
I mean, this happened
in Saint Petersburg.
Are you hearing anything about how,
if and how his death is impacting
others like him, other supporters
of Russia's
military operation in the invasion
from within Russia, yet
Yes, supporters.
And when
you mentioned supporters,
I think it's important to point out
that it's supporters like him, bloggers,
but also people who,
for instance,
support the war
in a more ideological way as well.
One of the things that we have to keep in
mind is that this is the second time
that a very prominent pro-war supporter
has been assassinated.
In August of last year,
I was in Moscow when Daria Dugin,
who's the daughter of Alexander
Dugin, one of the main sort of ideologues
who many say
delivers the ideological foundation
for Russia's war in Ukraine,
She was assassinated on a street
in Moscow and hit by a car bomb.
And now for the second time,
certainly this is something
that will send chills down
the spines
of many of the prominent people
who support Vladimir Putin's war
in Ukraine Kate.
So interesting.
Fred, thank you very much.
And John, there are a lot of questions
still about what's happened here,
but there's also a lot
this isn't the only news
coming out of Russia right now.
No, that's exactly right, Kate,
because just in Russian,
state media is reporting
that Wall Street
Journal reporter
Evan Gursky has filed an appeal
to his arrest, Gursky,
that faces up to 20 years in prison
after being arrested there last week.
He is the first U.S.
journalist
to be detained by Moscow
on espionage charges since the Cold War.
Secretary of State
Antony Blinken spoke
with the Russian Foreign Minister
Sergei Lavrov, to demand his release.
Lavrov blamed Washington
and the Western press
for politicizing the arrests
and said
the fate of Kovic would be determined
by a Russian court.
Secretary of State
Blinken also called
for the release of Paul
Whalen, who is serving a 16 year
sentence for espionage, which of course
Whalen and the U.S. disputes.
Blinken and Lavrov
have only spoken three times
since Russia invaded Ukraine.
Each of those calls
focused on trying to free
detained Americans.